exclusif vous est pris par surprise et
vu ça pollue tout marché aujourd'hui on
se retrouve sur eric brown ce qui est un
jeu d'avion et c'est parti mon gars
alors je crois qu'un objectif il ya
l'histoire de drapeaux je croyais que
pour le drapeau et le ramener à sa base
à regarder là bas il ya un truc rouge
qui volent oui j'ai la voix morte je
suis quelqu'un du miel s'il vous plaît
ça m'intéresse beaucoup
là du coup je suppose que je suis rouge
n'en attendait qu'est-ce qui se passe il
y avait un avion reliant une chaîne qui
s'est coincé un porte-clés ou alors un
porte avions je dirais qu'on est rouge
du couffo buts et les bleus on prend le
truc bleu ou au plus tard bon gars oh ça
va péter
qu'est-ce qui se passe allez on ramène
le flag tranquillement et se ramène le
drapeau c'est fantastique
aux premières actions non voilà là on a
capturé un drapeau mon cas on y retourne
de ce pain voilà moi je objectifs même
dans des jeux d'avion qu'est ce qui se
passe va faire un tricks avec l'hélice
c'était assez l'utfo conduit là notre
drapeau
on va les tuer c'est l'homme à battre on
va me tuer olaf rôle est il ou le petit
caux battle épique bataille épique où
les habitants c'était incroyable sylvain
de se passer jumbo une petite larme à
l'oeil non il est même plus dans ma
chambre c'est pas grave on a défendu
rien derrière c'est un ennemi c'est un
bleu hawass qui nous a mis parce que je
me suis mis tout seul dans le mur ce que
le mur nos amis je vais prendre en
chasse cet homme pas là bas on fait
comme si c'était une guerre d'investir
dans star wars ont le défaut sur le
défonce j'ai eu une explosion
via une explosion honte pour la chiasse
ça au fait pourquoi pas plus tard il m'a
carrément frôlé calme-toi aller on a eu
bien joué on regarde et on peut choisir
à dubaï où on avait ce truc là et là je
vois sniper l'avion ultra stylée donc là
je fais quand mais tu sais que ça
s'étire des nuages c'est ça j'ai vu un
bleu ça et voilà je tourne la tête comme
un gros con ça y est à quelqu'un a pris
drapeau à tanger le procès il faut que
je protège il ya un bleu là ok il ya une
hélice la papa bah faut qu'on protège
notre drapeau
voilà j'ai protégé j'ai fait une petite
caisse au passage suis leur donner de la
vie là je vois j'en vois au loin flammes
qui tire une chaîne j'aimerais bien
faire ça what
ok d'accord bafilo j'aimerais pas trop
ah vous avez tiré qu'une balle [ __ ]
une bonne note une balle est là y en a
un il est à nous ils à nous il a pété
ben je vais faire ça avec chaque avion
je veux dire qu'il a nous il va péter le
court il est faux tiens je t'envoie
nuage bogard et voilà on as tu regardé
c'est beau ce message là haut à gauche
bah il est déjà plus [ __ ] métier
mediaco avec prend un flex affiche 28
fois dans le chat au nom non faut que je
protège que je protège mes dents c'est
un mec avec nos impôts nous [ __ ]
hausse était bon il est où bon il va ou
bien un ennemi tué voilà [ __ ] c'est un
autre gars qu'il a eus je suis dégoûté
par échange d'actions quoi parce que tu
es des nuages ça va bien deux minutes
avant ses étincelles
tiens que c'est mieux oh il a pris mes
gars cher et c'est nous qui avons tué
sept fois pour fêter ça high five
voilà c'est un effet d avion peut
apprendre celui-là moyens qu'est-ce qui
lance sa il est sorti cet avion c'est ça
c'est un sorcier se doit laisser un truc
à moi ça je pense à oui ça laisse un
nuage de fumée violet très bien comme ça
les autres avions peuvent me rejoint de
dons et ont donc la tecktonik version
avions tous ensemble au la nôtre ilana
d'un pont non mais attends j'ai absolue
lancé des confettis quoi olala ils l'ont
eue je lance des morceaux de tissu bleu
quoi arrêter un moment aux fumées on
passe entre les immeubles non j'avais
j'avais pas vu la cheminée par lequel
passent que père noël finalement on lui
tire vénère homme je me fais ok mon gars
c'est un mec c'était pour esquiver le
local mais finalement je me suis fait
loca shakira que fais tu ici on t'a pas
invité [ __ ] toi non plus le mur bien
le lien bleu un bleu regardant le prend
en chasse
c'est à une mobylette avions russes un
bleu ça dans cette eau dense et je me
suis dit qu'est la voix et en plus il
était avec moi bataille face aux patrons
avions là il se pose regardez revue une
défense qui ont des fonctions
défonceront garde
il fait le gars a passé là dessous le
suis quand même j'aimerais gagner
qu'est ce qui se passe mon gars je
prouve mon appui m'a fait un caprice
quoi et voilà on est posé sans problème
à bon allez simplement de gloire
[Musique]
quoi mais pourquoi être chaud 0 0 au
tableau des scores
j'aime bien [ __ ] drapeau mon gars
qu'on a tous applaudi dans le tricot
elles étaient tous heureux c'était le
moment de gloire enlever ça mais alors
mes miss et pas les autres avions c'est
les toits bordel on bloque madame
annette petit on va l'escorté rien mais
qui prend en chasse et nous on prend en
chasse le mec qui le prend en charge à
satisfaire et y aller c'est moi le flag
un peu voilà bon je comprends pourquoi
me fait pas confiance maintenant [ __ ]
médiapart mais qui m'a blessé drapeau
tient aux 32 dents aux allées [ __ ] on
a pris un coup
la violence urbaine et steq quoi c'est
vraiment cet avion en bois finalement
qu'est le meilleur quoi regardez
regardez ça c'est beau ça allait
finalement surtout pour une vidéo sur
l'eau cursif même s'il n'y a pas de jeu
que le pouvoir des oreilles de lapinou
soit avec moi là bas là bas au loin à
l'os et transperçait mais c'est un allié
bordel et un hall avait explosion est
bien mort nullement on prend chaque mon
gars il est où je suis abonnée aux gars
qu'est ce qui se passe je pète un
postier et mais je m'en sors vivant ou
presque- mousty arrêt de bloquer
[ __ ] je le fais encore trouvé sur
cette fenêtre devant une femme qui se
déshabille
non mes mecs ses blagues tout le monde
joue avec ce [ __ ] avions killock quoi
bordel rampe original ça oui je joue
avec alors accélère tête deux bambins
oui pilote wallon avions décents tu
lèves le truc [ __ ] qu'est-ce qui se
passe
oh oui une boule qui fait du vent comme
ça mais tu connais tu attends quoi moga
à manger des chips taille du guacamole
avec lui et [ __ ] mais déchaîné mon
gars alors jeune homme on a du mal à
exploser
on l'a bien vu ci-dessus
j'ai tué astuces 1 avec un truc qui
gâche tout moment de gloire
et merde et la prochaine mon pote faut
que je protège apprécié jules a pas de
marquer et nikki l'aide et de me tuer
mais non je tue personne [ __ ] allez on
est en fait il a pété oui à grps ewen on
sait déjà fin de cette vidéo c'est
facile vous a plu même si j'en doute vu
le nombre de crashs qu'on s'est pris
dans la gueule r ça va regarder ça vous
a plu n'hésitez pas à mais la vidéo ont
surtout retrouvé dans une nouvelle vidéo
chat au monde pique ça
[Musique]
elle